hi Sadie hi and so first question do you
have any similarity to actually in real
life yeah for sure we both are really
much into music we love sport I love
rugby Archy plays football
if only he played by beardy dope and I
think his relationship with his dad I'm
really close with my dad I'll continue
from New Zealand think about how a
different accent it was no secret but
how did you like nail the American
accent how to see you worship I didn't
really it's interesting I didn't work on
it or really I mean I worked on it by
myself but I didn't really I was kind of
just one of those things that I was able
to do and I'm lucky in that respect I
think because it means I don't have to
focus on it when I'm working I can kind
of just keep it focused on the work so
yeah it happens I can I can but I can't
do it it's probably not as good as the
American just because of how much I do
the American now but I'd love to be
involved or selling with appreciation do
you personally want Artie together with
wanna cut or Betty to the right hand
side I can't decide either neither
cannot see but uh yeah I get asked that
all the time
it's not really for me to comment on if
I do the internet will probably explode
but yeah I'll leave it up to the to the
writing for sure so none of everyone
knows that you have a very much three of
them cold spell yeah okay and did you
have an instant romantic connection no
definitely was an instant in the
beginning yeah no I'm not he's good guy
I took a yeah it took us a while to
become you know close what do you like
doing it together the Hangout I would
campaign would be I think we actually
drove we drove to we drive back to LA
from Vancouver which was sick I was a
really nice trip and we've we've been
camping out in Canada which is really
beautiful
yeah so you paid a good time your life
yeah anything on the show and we would
be seeing you in the charts anytime soon
on the chart yeah maybe one day
hopefully um I don't know that would be
cool I would like that he
would be a dream duet partner gon
partner I dreamed you a partner progress
how you feel like now at uni cheering
it'll probably be gentle edge in high
school probably to the head to that to
be alive okay Steve you're a born I'd
say okay yeah these are legends one my
favorite it's your birthday coming up
soon how will you be celebrating I will
be on a plane with my best mate so at
least I'm with my best mate which is
which is right but I'll be on a plane
which concepts in crazy thing I'll get
Geneva dark accent really so you seeing
you with perhaps yeah and what was your
reaction when you find out that you
began a hair transformation for the well
I was kind of nervous I was nervous
because I wasn't sure how I look with
with red here and I was thinking if I
look like a complete idiot
maybe they'll recast me myself okay
someone who looks better with read here
um but yeah I I got it done and I've had
it done every two weeks now
which is kind of gnarly but it's just
part of it it's just part of the job so
you said that season two is going to get
dark that we want my with is like before
they're asleep anymore though anymore in
spectators okay we kept under the dark
for a lot of it I mean we get the script
like the night before we start shooting
as well but yet we were getting I mean
obviously we have the new Reggie coming
in and other writers really want to dive
into that and explore that character
it's going to get really dark for Archie
with his dad with his dad being shot I
think you know where the Fred lives or
dies it's going to change Archie's life
for sure I think we're going to see a
completely different side to him there's
going to be a lot of it's going to be a
lot of relationship relationship
conflicts I'd say yeah and more shipping
for you guys probably